hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space to UM Condor aroma
I've done baby we owe their own hey
Julie what the heck kind of suburban
maybe fight
okay and I killed the other one finally
I finally got it too
it's not a lot of good that did me just
try it
I don't even know what I'm looking for
something about a tram I don't trust you
how do your luck
ah
come on there we go
ah what no baby boy
gotcha not a devil
that
dead bodies store over there jump out at
me didn't think so
okay I can have that yeah that schematic
and also this oh I got to go no good Oh
from the big thing oh yeah so yeah so
dad so dad I got lots of line rags gun
you know what I mean
I need plasmon good old-fashioned move
mayor that's what I need some fancy
javelins actually what have I got in my
bag oh yeah I've got plenty Oh someone
said that I just need to sell this
because it's no good
algobit
who knows what dastardly demons away oh
I put that in the oh when you put your
suits in storage
okay all right now I'm gonna try to be
good with the detonator
[Music]
gotta just try to get me Oh what that uh
Spica come on come on what's the point
of even having the den there if it
doesn't like if I'm too stupid to use it
I blame myself I should put them on the
walls didn't even give me a damn thing
oh there we go let me go let me just go
ahead and sell them I mean I know I have
inventory space but the stores right
here so I might as well I might as well
whatever no not that
now save it I need to use it I need to
get good
I know it could be a devastating
offensive weapon as well as a defensive
weapon if you get
I should I should get the flamethrower
with my firefighter suited look I just
lifted
huh huh Oh breakable glass oh so don't
put that there
I need to be safe good
I knew something No Thank You H again
why would they design the emergency
hatch to need to be shot if I was
designing a space station I would holy
[ __ ] is it white no is that
is that the use of era
if I was designing a ship I wouldn't
have the bulkheads only slam down after
they were shot like a design oversight
back to the explosives
what the hell see you huh uh-huh
whatever I only looked out for the best
for you don't just move see how that
work how well that worked out will you
fire stick
ah boom boom there we go detonators
amazing response there's another fire
stick right there ha ha oh the poor baby
and if they could see the likes of you
again but now that I think about this
sort of infectious stuff is bound to be
growing I guess this isn't going to be
the last time I'll see you any of this
is that what I'm going for
looks like a trail let's go
god
come up what the hell now
fine fine
whatever you don't matter to me I'll
just waste some time going back down
that thing on fire it is supposed to be
on fire that denies that work
you think there just be a direct route I
was designing this place who would not
design it the way it is ah nope nope try
to get to me
I see you little guys Oh what yeah oh
sure
Wang got you
[Music]
there's the tram all I bet I just got to
figure out a way to get it
jaysus ahead
looks like one of those discs from Tron
[Music]
um
I don't know Oh blue
Oh Oh there's a disk and there's it it's
okay I got a disconnect in there okay
okay I thought I might have a space
except maybe not
why did I need to take it away from
those two
I demand answers I don't have enough
power to us did that do anything at all
did it no it did not
everything's on fire
oh here we go oh it looks like these
huh how'd you get there damn it why
can't I hit your limb
now David Gaia YouTube hobby
go for the arms
kill you with your own thing state dead
Hey down this is your friend Stacy says
safe going on all right
[Music]
hello I'm that kind of guy but I'm not
making fun of my battle I am hello crazy
and not so crazy
oh I'm just gonna leave you out there
for a while I could let you in but I
choose our actor babe you made it yes I
did
staring at me I see structures the holes
in East has to make in his head so max
relax I don't talk to me like that right
let's go
and I move might not allow to move
oh my god
it was nasty shimmer uh-huh yeah used to
be the pride of the CC sad story
actually I had everybody on board died
some sort of terrorist lips they covered
it up and then they brought it into
brought the infection tears detect what
happened for that [ __ ] was not terrorist
attack we mean that's where all this
started le everything that's happening
here happened on that ship I saw it
happen what's happening what's happening
Oh degrowth I'll take a look Sam so
brave yeah so baby how are you doing
nice job pushing buttons that aren't you
there good job anyway
how you doing straws doing okay a lot of
huh yeah yeah yeah burnt which okay
anyhoo something
uh-uh
[Music]
detonator things for tumors ah hello
Jimmy
I need something to throw at those
things come on gimme I guess I didn't
need to grab it it whatever I'll get
over it
[Music]
ah
no just try it do it oh yeah okay I'll
be right back guys ah le help me do
something stop standing there pushing
buttons and help me okay fine that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you guys so much for playing trying
watching thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye